then it's a four-point lead after the
mccullum bucket
one yes it was and won and then it's a
one-point game
on the line levert no
blazers corral the rebound and the
victory by
1-134 to 133
breaking hearts in phoenix because the
suns are
out and portland is into that game they
will have to beat memphis
once memphis has to beat them twice in
that play-in scenario
blazers by a single digit here's terry
[Applause]
down here we wanted stocks get in the
playing game we did that
we wanted to get the ac we did that
we're finishing it off
[Applause]
and so here's the way it ended up with
portland and memphis set to
go at it on saturday head-to-head and
again portland needs
one win against memphis memphis has to
beat the blazers twice and then the
western conference playoff field will be
set phoenix is out
san antonio is out phoenix the first
team in nba history
to end the regular season on an
eight-game winning streak
and miss the playoffs wow out of first
wow what a night well i can say this
everybody won
everybody won in the bubble
phoenix grew up and matured they can
feel good going into the off-season
i think coach popovich is happy with the
way his young team is
memphis play they deserve to be in the
playoffs
because they were the best hc throughout
the regular season yeah went in with a
three and a half games
and the portland trailblazers this is
healthy as they probably been all year
they are a three or four seed if they're
healthy all year
it's gonna be fascinating this play-in
game
or two or two yeah i i think the one
thing about
you know what we see with portland is
and that that happened actually when the
clipper game when um
when kawhi sent out and and dane mr free
throws his
offensive rebounds they when montreal's
harold
comes back and starts playing with the
clippers and you have
uh you have all of these kind of guys
and that's in the those
those are the every team has one of
those in the playoffs
so uh if they don't do a job of
boxing out and allowing lebron james's
or even even uh john marantz uh
second and third and fourth shots they
can find themselves
out quickly but if they rebound there is
no team in the bubble that could score
as easy as that team
would you agree with that a hundred
percent i don't know one two there's no
score there's no team
because clay and steph are not here that
back court either one that can go off
trent is playing like a man possessed
nurchick
is doing his thing camelo had 20 of the
last three games before tonight
and i haven't even got to zach collins
in whiteside yet
i was i was surprised because nurkic
could not keep up with jared allen he
should have made a switch and put in
collins
or whiteside kawhi had whiteside played
15 minutes
has 16 points and nine rebounds you got
to go with matchups but
that team right there they play zero
defense
the one advantage they got if they get
to the lakers
the lakers can't score like that
and but they're gonna at some point they
you're gonna have to play defense ernie
and what's the last part of chief
kenny oh rebounding rebounding last part
of defenses again you're wrong mccullum
played good defense to end the game
second of all portland showed me a lot
because with dame going 51-41-61 the
others didn't have a chance to shine
we knew they were going to take the ball
out of their hands and i and they
stepped up well tonight
very proud of them nurkic uh 22. carmel
uh mccullum 25
dame 42 and then gary trent 16 and osan
16.
that's all you need from the other yeah
but all you're doing is talking about
offense
this brooklyn wins championships
defensively
yeah i've heard defense wins
championships uh it didn't help you in
phoenix when y'all was playing defense
that's [ __ ] that gotta hit a shot
first of all one guy beat y'all paxton
no no see that's right that's what you
don't even know what you're talking
about
because i'm gonna beat you no mother
beat you no first of all you need me
i don't know what i'm talking because i
was there you weren't there other
beaches
others need to step up ernie period so
you know ernie i mean
defense is cool but all [ __ ] what
people don't know about that game we
lost that game defensively
we had we basically scored that game and
he hit a shot no
it wasn't a tie game fool pay attention
it was
we had we have we had a six point lead
and they scored seven straight points i
really don't want to talk about 1997. oh
yeah because you know what it was 92.93
i don't know what i don't talk about
what's going on in 2000. the portland
trailblazers just like kenny said
they are the most gifted offensive team
in this play in the bubble in the bubble
i'm looking at i'm trying to think of
anyone you know even houston
yeah with no yeah but but you're not
going to outscore everybody
it's a it's a number five offensive team
in the league and number 27 defensively
the portland trailblazers
one thing um that i saw um
and and we all witnessed it when dame
lillard came down
and shot that three from from half court
and
all i could think about was when we were
on hiatus
and i'm doing all those nba togethers
and one of my guests
was damien lillard and you know what he
said that night what's that
play it when it's all said and done in
your career
what will your uh comfortable shooting
range be
because right now it's up to where 35
feet
i mean i could shoot a i could pull up
from half court comfortably
the only reason i haven't done it is
because i don't want to i don't want to
push the i don't want to push it that
far
consistently because that is just that's
just crazy but
i literally i can literally do it i told
terry i'm gonna do it too and he was
like
he was like well i used to get mad when
you shot those deep threes and now you
just make them
because you you work at it is it just a
good shot for you take it
i was like i'm gonna do it i gave him
the warning already
yeah he had guaranteed in in these in
these uh seating games
i haven't seen a guy shoot it i mean
steph
shoots it from there but it doesn't look
as comfortable
that looks effortless and
i i don't i don't know we talk about
steph being staffordless but
the energy that he takes to actually do
that shot
or shoot from that range in that speed
at times
that's the most impressive part of him
134
133 the portland trailblazers winners
over the brooklyn nets in a
thriller to wrap up our triple header
night barkley pick portland to beat the
lakers
oh hey george danny murphy a
guaranteed
you had to be happy i'll call my man you
may have been having your doubts a
little bit tonight there chuckster i
mean
listen i was
that's pretty hard i'll tell you hey i
like that that's pretty funny right i'd
rather see